how's it going bros my name is peter pan
oh my god pewdiepie ripped pewdiepie so
strong this is basically been all over
any form of social media oh my god
ah
it's basically been plastered on my
subreddit they even had to close down
the subreddit because people kept
posting about it this isn't the y
however but 54 000 people want a workout
review
so that's what we're gonna do today i'm
i wasn't planning to talk about it or
make a video like this in a long time at
least i don't know six months a year to
for me to actually gain some muscle i'm
not ripped okay
i'm just lean or what there's a
difference
i i feel like i still have a long way to
go but what happened was i was putting
up some light outside i mean i was
challenging ceiling gang
as you can see
my workout routine
100 tambourine hits a day
hundred
might say came out and she was like damn
so she snapped the photo of me and then
she we both looked at it like what the
even i was shocked i hadn't even worked
out that day it's not like i was pumped
up or anything so she she shared it on
her social media because you know it's
lame if i share it
and god damn people freaked out
did not expect that i guess since people
always i've always been very skinny for
a very long time and people also always
see me like that so you gain any form of
muscle and people are like what yeah
this is me before
yep
oh yeah there it is i'm glad that photo
exists and uh yeah this is me now i
guess at the end at the end of the
montage i need a couple more montages
come on
i even saw people online debating if i'm
using droids or any sort of supplements
it's like i don't even know what they're
talking about i don't know what it means
i'm not that strong
and other people just going like oh oh
he's got he's super rich he's got like a
super good trainer pumping him every day
and he's got like this insane gym at
home he can afford it so i thought why
don't i just start off by showing uh
what my gym looks like welcome and
here's my gym set up
edgar spots me thank you very much for
doing that so basically it's just this
uh what is it called bench
it's garbage it's so bad
it's so wonky i swear to god i feel like
if i ever die it's because this thing
collapses on me
half the time the screws are coming off
and i have to keep screwing them in so
it doesn't fall down
hey hey goodnight
these are super nifty
uh and the way they work is that um you
can very quickly change each weight that
you want you want 30 40 60 50 70. it
goes up to 90 actually
uh i have 90 here that's why
and even 10 without anything
so if i want 30
bam
lift up ready to go and that's why i
have this wrist protection because it
hits my wrist sometimes
and it hurts a lot so i got these i
actually recommend it if you're using
these
plus you feel more badass somehow i
don't know why
it does have a problem which is that if
i want to make a a jump it's a high jump
to go from 80 to 90 pounds that's uh
from
from 36 kilos to 41 instead of going
from 36 kilos to maybe
38 or 39 uh it takes me a lot longer to
jump in in weight basically that's the
problem i have with these but it saves
you a lot of money and a lot of space to
not have a whole rack with dumbbells
which would be nice i should probably
get that but these are cheaper
i also have these
which are good for
it's good it's good for extra grit when
you're doing pull exercises
um
they're okay they're not that great it's
just very frustrating hey i'm filming
this is very frustrating when um
you're trying to hit a weight and you
know you can do it but you're losing
grip
i hate that so much so these help
uh and that's pretty much it i put my
workout journal here
next to all the
all the chemicals
so i write down all the this is me day
one i was doing flat press 50. i was
doing 70 and then i could do
it's not that bad actually i haven't
improved that much it's just i hurt my
arm recently so i haven't really
i'm careful i'm careful with the show
here because sometimes i write down i
get angry and i write down a bunch of
[ __ ]
do it [ __ ]
so it's notes for me for the next week i
always go through what i did the
previous week so i'm like yeah next time
do this [ __ ] you wimp right arm weak
very compared to left
yeah this was
two weeks ago i hurt my arm this is
probably dumbbells and don't make the
mistakes i made properly warm up make
the right movements because if you get
injured you're you're out for three
weeks at least it takes that long for
the muscles to recover and it's very
easy to get damaged with dumbbells i
also hurt my back from
lifting down the dumbbells which is
equally important so if you're working
out with dumbbells be careful i'm saying
it to myself in the past
it's not worth it to get injured just
take it slow but yeah i think it's cool
i like the idea that anyone can pick up
this
in their house it's very small it
doesn't take up a lot of space and it's
fairly
cost efficient if you have if you don't
have access to a gym this is a pretty
good base i would say uh gym is always
better because you're going to have
machines and you're not going to hurt
yourself like i do like an idiot that's
my setup setup tour i know my my setup
is written i know i could get more but i
i just really like the idea that i can
move it anywhere
uh it feels very liberating to have that
kind of setup and you can do a ton with
dumbbells like i said in the videos so
just be careful that's all so i've never
actually spoken about my
workout history or whatever in 2016 i
had never been to a gym before in my
entire life and i i didn't know anything
i didn't know how to properly squat i
didn't know what reps meant i didn't
know what sets meant i
but i wanted to try and get in shape in
better shape at least so i kind of
forced myself to go to a gym i uh i was
terrified i had no idea what to expect
and
it was just a the overconfidence in me
just said okay you just go in there and
just how hard can it be you just put up
and down weights anyone can do that
don't be me basically what i'm saying if
you've never been touching before ask a
friend to introduce you or or even
better ask one of the personal trainers
at the gym they'll definitely be one and
they'll help you out i keep seeing the
sentiment that people that are maybe
overweight or or
don't feel confident about their body or
feel like they're going to be judged or
something like that that just couldn't
be further from true and i gotta say the
personal trainers that i've worked with
have just been the most motivating and
supportive
uh people
because that's their job you know it's
uh so definitely don't be scared to do
that and to just get started a lot of
gyms will offer one personal trainer for
free
so it's a hundred percent worth it
absolutely you need to know what you're
doing going into a gym so i shortly
after i switched gyms and i got started
with a personal trainer which was really
good he taught me how to really push
myself how to work out with dumbbells
ironically this is me after going to the
gym
you can tell there's some muscle
maybe i don't know i think the most
strong i was at the time was uh in this
video you can sort of tell there's some
muscle there
but not a lot
the elena
i think she likes it
this was really good the problem was
that i didn't have a goal with my
exercise i just sort of went with it
which was a big mistake and i knew you
know at the back of my mind i was
working myself to the point where i was
throwing up you know i was really almost
i wasn't actually throwing up but when
you feel like oh god i cannot give any
more uh which is common when you start
off and you haven't worked out before
but in the back of my mind i was like
there's no way i can maintain this for a
longer time you know
so lo and behold i got sick i got a
stomach flow that was really bad and it
knocked me out for two to three weeks
and after that i just
i just never picked it up again and any
sort of progress that i've gained from
from those months at the gym
after a year
you know i was still
fit but most of the games were gone
and so i decided to myself okay i'll
just set up a bench i'll set up some
dumbbells at home and i can just work
out from that you know and this time i'm
not going to make the same mistake i'm
just going to be consistent and i'm not
going to overdo it so i did that for a
year this really measly workout just to
be consistent because you know i've been
consistent on youtube and that's sort of
been my success so that can translate
into exercise and uh yeah it just got to
a point where i was fed up and i
i wanted to really start pushing myself
and i did that two months ago and that's
when i really started to notice the big
difference that you've seen in in the
photos today and this is actually
reading a lot of books reading a lot of
philosophy you guys know i'm a fan of
mishima so if you know mishima that's
pretty self-explanatory
for those who don't know mishama was an
author that was absolutely ripped he
talked a lot about body
and action
uh which is a message today that seems
completely lost and i read a bunch of
other books as well that helped me
develop my philosophy around exercise
which seems kind of cringey and and
like it doesn't match no work at it
that's for dummies which couldn't be
further from the truth
if anything body and soul are deeply
connected and i wanted them to match and
that's why i really wanted to start
pushing myself with my workout so this
time i had a clear goal what i was
getting into so i just needed to push
myself this time but how i didn't have i
don't have a personal trainer anymore
so i sort of became my own personal
trainer i knew which workout that was
needed to be done i just didn't know how
to not slack off because it's easy to
slack off when you work out on your own
it's totally possible to to work out on
your own but it's always better with a
trainer or a friend or with someone else
so i started tracking down my training i
i wrote down in a journal which you saw
earlier
my reps
my sets
the weights and how much
uh rest time i would keep and i would
really try and push myself each time to
make sure i was making progress in
retrospect i don't think that was the
most important thing to do the most
important thing is to really
do it until you fail like you can't push
any longer that should be the goal
instead but it worked out for me uh so
my workout routine finally we got to it
i'm sorry for so much talking
so mondays
i do push exercises i do chest
heavily on chest everyone keeps making
fun of my chest in the in the photo but
it looks better in person trust me it's
massive i got huge titties and then i
finish off with shoulders i don't
remember it in my head but it's
something like that and then tuesdays i
do leg squats deadlifts yadda yadda
lunges
and then wednesday i do pull exercises
then thursday i do leg a leg again and
then friday i finish with a mix of push
and pull i know there's other variations
of this sort of workout that are more
efficient and i'm probably going to
change my workout pretty soon but it
worked out for me so far uh i literally
just googled online like five day
dumbbell workout and you can probably
find it yourself and follow it so or
maybe i'll i'll leave a link to in the
description if you want to try what i
did the most important thing is to
really push yourself until you fail but
the next thing
which is very important and people
always say that it's important but then
they just ignore it anyway
but it is equally important because when
you're lifting weight you're only
burning so many calories no matter how
heavy of an exercise you don't really
lose weight where lifting weights
ironically
you have to change your diet if you want
to lose body fat and probably the
biggest difference for me was cutting
out alcohol
which is something i talked about before
i'd say maybe a year ago i quit alcohol
for the first time as you guys know i
like my whiskey too much i like my
whiskey too much which was
not healthy i didn't feel good about it
so i quit alcohol completely and i did
that for a couple months and i felt hey
great you know i can actually do this
but then afterwards i just fell back
into my old habits and i felt cheeky and
terrible about it like i was slowly
killing myself it's great so so i
basically made the same mistake i did
with my workout as i did with my eating
or drinking rather and there is
obviously a lot of calories in drinking
that's not the reason i quit but it
helps to have another reason uh to quit
it i decided to just cut off hard liquor
from my
palette
i just realized it's not for me if other
people like it that's great i just no
i'm not doing it never again
uh i do drink maybe like a pint of beer
once a week if i'm hanging out with
friends online or whatever i drink
socially basically that's what i'm
saying
so it always doesn't talk about how it's
important to let your spirit loose and i
kind of agree with that i was i think
the problem was before when i quit
drinking is that i was too strict on it
i didn't want to be that person in the
friend group and uh i think this way i'm
just gonna be able to to stick with it
and honestly quitting drinking it it was
hard it was a habit that i had developed
and like
you probably have some food or some
craving that you really feel strongly
about maybe you don't realize that
you're addicted to it but once you cut
it out of your uh your diet that's when
you realize that you are addicted to it
and you sort of just like you train
yourself to like that food and depend on
that food you have to train yourself to
not be dependent on it and that's really
tough in the beginning but once you get
out of it you gain a whole different
perspective and you
even me looking back on my old drinking
habits i really look back on it with the
test and and the shame of my past self
you have to realize that sensational
pleasures don't bring happiness and as
soon as you take that first
bite
it's already fleeting it's not gonna
make you happy i i feel like there's
almost a social idea that you need food
to be happy oh i need these food because
they make me happy or whatever sorry
that this video just became me ranting
about different topics hopefully it is
helpful for people to understand my
mindset because i really think mindset
is one of the most important things if
you want to work out you can obviously
anyone can pick up working out for a
little while but unless you have the
right mindset you're not going to be
able to be consistently pushing yourself
for it one of the best things i've done
out of all of these and the change of my
life that i'm the most happy about
is i looked up how much protein i needed
you can do this as well i'll link a
website down below so you can put in
your weight you can put in your height
and then you can put in how much you
work out and then it tells you okay well
this
is roughly what your daily protein
intake should be and mine was just
way off
so i started just stuffing myself with a
bunch of protein snacks you know protein
bars
nuts that have a lot of protein it's not
as great but it's if you want something
savory it's good this was life-changing
for me because i used to struggle a lot
with anger i never really i talked about
actually my socialism video about anger
and
i had made the habit of being very angry
often and
very confrontational
and aggressive at first i liked that
part of myself because i thought oh this
is another sort of image of a man kind
of like whiskey is seen as manly you
know it's it's society looks at anger a
lot of ways as something manly as well
and i think recognizing these things as
as just that and i started meditating on
it a lot and i was able to control my
anger much much better so this doesn't
really help me that as well but i would
still
you know feel it i would still feel that
anger even though i didn't act on it the
same way i used to i would feel happy i
would virtuous by the fact that i wasn't
acting on my anger anymore but i wasn't
my happy self that i would you normally
used to be as much as i would like to at
least
but protein makes you so so much fuller
and it doesn't make your at least for me
my blood sugar spike as much so that
problem for me which was a big problem
just completely disappeared just by me
trying to eat more protein so i'm so
happy i made that change
it wasn't intentional but it's just
something that just worked out really
well for me i guess uh last thing
working out will not solve all your
problems it will not fix any sort of
issues there's obviously many reasons to
work out that are very positive you you
will you'll look better you'll feel more
confident you'll be more healthy but
these are obviously degenerate reasons
to work out you exercise
you ex you lift weights for mishima okay
you lift weights for homer you lift
weights to escape
abstract concepts like time and death
that's the only acceptable reasons and
just lastly if you feel good about
yourself already there's
there's no shape whatever size or shape
you are i don't care all right that's if
you feel good about yourself i great
excellent this is not a video to make it
like you have to be like this or you
have to have this mindset to be happy
this is something that worked for me and
i'm very happy about it and it's been
really motivational as well to see so
many support around it i think that's
great and i really appreciate it i
really feel like uh
jim bros are the most supportive people
out there so yeah this is my progress so
far maybe in a year i'll make another
video when i more in depth on my workout
once i actually know how to do it
properly i don't want to
spread misinformation and stuff like
that but i i feel confident in what i
said today at least so yeah thanks for
watching
brofist
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign